[Music]
huh it's you you're gonna get me in
trouble drop D something could hear me I
wish someone wanted to hear me other
than you I know I'm not supposed to love
music no music no music but my
great-grandma Coco's father was the
greatest musician of all time ernesto de
la cruz one day he left with his guitar
and never returned my family thinks
music is occurs great-great-grandfather
none of them understand me I'm supposed
to play music alright losing you're
really out there agents at the
Department of family reunions are
available solicits do for a living boy
begin you here we're your family
I know your great-grandpa I'll get you
to him what are you doing skeleton no
skeletons don't walk like that that's
how you walk no I don't when there's no
one left in the living world who
remembers you you disappear from this
world but you can change that we've
gotta find my cricket grandpa you've got
a do it by Sunrise what happens at
Severns you'll be stuck your fruit oh
I'm a big fan
never born big how much your family
loves you
it's almost sunrise one cannot deny who
one is meant to be it doesn't have any
hair and I don't have a nose and yet
here we are
you